vous avez dû en voir passer des badel et
qu'est ce qu'elle vous dise
jacky vous avez dû en voir passer des
vedettes tout
non sauf une eddie barclay et qu'est-ce
qu'il dit lui il ne dit pas monsieur
il sait aurait dit bonsoir bonsoir était
en forme ça va que va bien tout va bien
tu vois toujours en blanc les vacances
la fabrique t dictée dans le midi tu
t'habilles en blanc quoi ah oui ça passe
mieux à la machine nous fait changer
tous les jours
tout va bien tu as quel âge l'a71
maintenant ouais on verra après talât
bourg quand même non nantes où vas tu
vas te voir une femme charmante ses amis
adorable uns des artistes qui
m'entourent et nos activités et
débordante
dis moi tu as eu ce cancer quand même
bien il ya un peu plus de dix ans
maintenant
on ne meurt pas toujours unis va de
temps en temps il te regarde regarde le
contrôle du bon ça va jamais encore
cameroonian avait encore du temps tous
les combien de bergers étaient contrôlés
à l'aubergine est contrôlé à peu près
toutes les heures et demie c'est à dire
tu bois tu vois combien de deux bergers
par jour douzaine d'ailleurs je vais
faire un berger barclay parce que
maintenant
on m'a lancé ça au mois de septembre moi
je dois boire beaucoup d'eau en plus je
bois du perdu avec un produit beaucoup
d'eau par jour alors une douzaine une
douzaine de films et ça ne tourne pas la
tête
jamais ça ne change pas donc les femmes
qui puisse me tourner et si tu en vois
pas qu'est ce qui se passe
rires je bois du bordeaux ouais mais si
tu vois pas de berger pas de bordeaux
c'est grave je meurs alors il business
ça marche
j'ai fait des affaires toujours nagé une
dizaine de sociétés qui collaient des
productions particulière alors allons-y
alors il ya d'abord le les disques via
les leafs il s'appelle comment les
disques barclay beattie barclay dit marc
gibard kiev il ya une société qui
organise des fêtes qui organise les
fêtes ça se passe comment s'en veut se
faire organiser une fête par barclays
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
on téléphone 1 mon téléphone de mon
collaborateur alain marois ni et
un particulier s'est plus fait pour
lancer un produit pur c'est pas un grand
mariage union de manifestations
quelqu'un soit et puis on organise par
rapport à la personnalité lui organise
la fête sur mesure avec 2 les orchestres
nationalement citizen bézy fédérateur
pour les fêtes
tu garantit les stars ne veut pas il
peut jamais garantir leicester mais on
peut en faire venir et ça coûte combien
une fête organisée par barclays entre
500 1000 et 1
on avait quand même les mecs te paye
toujours toujours lama qui dit c'était
pas bien
non non non l'a examiné lui est pas
venue de johnny d'arriver en retard
n'est jamais arrivé ces chaînes privées
ça fait combien de fait par an de
l'organisme combien une demi douzaine à
caen mais on a quand même l arrêt ton
parfum alors le parfum on l'a sorti il
ya quelques quelques mois a rappelé le
parfum saint tropez et le maire de saint
tropez monsieur spada lui n'est pas
content lui dit qu'on n'a pas le droit
de prendre le volant de sa ville pour se
l'attribuer à des fins commerciales
je ne pensais pas si pas de londres sa
ville c'est le nom de la ville de sa
ville aujourd'hui les maires de sa
primaire donc ça veut pas ça veut pas
dire que c'est sa ville sa ville comme
si la mienne rien donc ne trompait pas
s'attribuer le nom d'une ville parce
qu'on puisse entrer s'attribuer le nom
de paris mais ça la rend par exemple
sorti un parfum qui s'appelle parler de
l'ief chaleureux hommage est sorti sans
trappe et du barclays toute cette bande
de saint tropez convoi dans paris match
ou visiter à sellaband si mabanda - film
- c'est la demande heures avec
les gens qui veulent absolument faire
partie de la bande ils sont prêts à
quelle bassesse pour y arriver
bonne question
quelle bassesse news 1,8 royalement il
envoie des avions d'hélicoptères
quelques fois même de son plat donner de
l'argent
tout ça pour vous avoir chez chez eux
oui ou venir chez nous et le pire que tu
as vu dans le genre c'est quoi oui deux
jours qui viennent en hélicoptère
ils viennent quelquefois s'imposer comme
ça les sort dans sur le terrain pour
aider des gens qui attendent même
derrière les grilles de la
le lot de la porte dans l'autre et y
force presque la porte d'orléans voilà
on voterait vous
et un tableau enfin toute la nature est
incroyable et tu fais quoi pour t'en
débarrasser
je suis pas là alors tu sais que t'es
pas l'archipel vous êtes connu comme en
danse un casting c'est à dire casting à
lyon
ouais je fais des castings pour trouver
ces femmes turques restait quoi leur
expliquent nos noms je casse tête pour
trouver de nouvelles jolie marque est
déjà bon oui je suis avec mon ami robert
hossein et ça va se faire 2
trouver la nouvelle du chêne merci je
trouvais cette dame
tu m'as garder pour toi finalement oui
c'est moi mais ça s'est passé comment au
départ je vous dire comment et à draguer
en gros quoi bon ça je suis allé à ce
casting avec des copines parce qu'en
fait
allez pourvoir uni barclays pour paris
et puis donc m'a dit que c'était joué au
théâtre j'ai dit que moi en fait jamais
fait de théâtre que c'est pas du tout
avoir
tallon iv et donc jeudi par contre
j'étais intéressé par les touches et la
communication les relations publiques et
des charges envisagé de faire d'ailleurs
des stages à la rentrée c'est parti bon
pour résumer la chose en fait pendant
six mois je monte régulièrement à paris
à chaque fois pendant six mois je
rappelle toi tu vas pas céder pendant
six mois et un jour tu as aidé j'ai cédé
c'est compliqué c'est ce qu'il a fait
pour te faire céder il s'est fâché une
fois donc au bout pratiquement de six
mois il m'a appelé à lyon tout ce temps
là il était d'une patience allemande une
galanterie stastiques veut avant tout
énervé quoi il faut arrêter de traiter
de quoi de bernadette soubirous à la
lutte a envie de vivre avec moi et alors
là la chose s'est fait très rapidement
dans oui on s'est plus vu pendant
quelques temps qui quand même
il a rappelé et il a rappelé à ce moment
là non à paris m'a pas rappelée elle est
arrivée avec ses valises raccourci
raccourci mais celles habilitées
d'approuver de vente à tort cette
pratique me battais jeudi que bien passé
le week-end et manon je sors je viens à
inviter des groupes à 1 et alors là ça
fait cinq ans vous êtes mariés ça se
passe comment leur faisons un petit
bilan
est ce que il est fidèle c'est tous
ensemble qu'ils verraient oui un enfant
non je suis fidèle des fidèles
j'imagine je crois tu crois oui je crois
moi dis moi alors maintenant question
importante est ce que c'est vrai que
valence
non pas du tout déçu j'envoie gens font
certainement dans ma vie ouais ben
s'assure la jeune torera non non
franchement mais il a bien rempli n'a
pas dit avant que l'épousé tu sais ça va
être très dur avec moi tu n'auras jamais
l'enfant était au contraire tout ce
qu'il m'a dit il ya quelques temps si
j'en avais envie il était d'accord aussi
donc là c'est pour vous en faites pas
alors
pour différentes raisons d'abord j'ai
deux enfants d'une part d'autre part
j'ai 75 ans je me demande si vraiment
sur viviano faut maintenant sur la suite
des événements ça c'est difficile à
vivre centenaire toi oui j'ai bien dit
normand fin à dix mois et et huit femmes
toi quand même non levitt n 1 le plus
belle ouais en fait à divorcer que six
fois parce que ta première femme est
décédée au bout d'un an et demi de
mariage
et est ce que tu crois que si ça n'était
pas arrivé
est ce que tu crois que tu réussis comme
ça tout c'est toutes ces femmes
tous tes paroles georges pas bon dans la
vie j'aime c'est par hasard
est ce que tu dis je t'aime ah oui oui
vous serez galant il sait y faire avec
les femmes c'est mieux les mecs ans
d'expérience
donc j'aime pas les hommes qui sont trop
sûrs d'eux et ça rien à voir avec
l'expérience
c'est pour ça que je préfère contrôler
les hommes
certains d'entre nous sont moins sûrs de
promotion de l'hygiène par le connais
bien on sait bien comment s'y prendre
aussi non ah oui bien l'expérience dans
tous les domaines - tu vas rester avec
lui ben s'il reste sympa comme ça oui
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus